Коноплі — широко розповсюджена
культура в усьому світі.
Я, можна сказати, закоханий
в цю культуру конопель.
Я тут сказав би, що не без того,
чим наділили батьки,
хоча вони були простими селянами.
Але вони навчили мене спостережливості.
Коноплі — досить цікава культура
в плані еволюції.
Я сказав би,
що вони відображають еволюційну
історію нашого землеробства.
Рости вони можуть де завгодно,
на будь-яких землях,
на маргінальних,
тобто закинутих землях,
які не придатні для використання.
Ось там прекрасно ростуть коноплі.
Окремі розсадники в нас
ізольовані один від одного,
не менше як на півтора-два кілометри.
То треба добиратись,
проводити там догляди.
У поле ми виїжджаємо майже
щодня літньо-осіннього періоду.
Власне селекція —
це не така проста робота.
Це робота досить складна.
Вона пов’язана з тим,
щоб виявити, що гірше, а що ліпше.
Двох однакових селекціонерів,
які в одному напрямку
працювали, немає.
Кожен, залежно від своєї освіти,
від свого, можна сказати
(я не соромлюсь цього), таланту,
бачить шляхи створення
нового селекційного матеріалу.
Ось якраз ми ступаємо на площу,
де проводиться селекційне
сортовипробування.
Але як же взнати?
Треба порівняти із чимось —
чи ліпше, чи гірше.
Для цього прийнято в селекції стандарти.
Як і в повсякденному житті,
ми все з чимось порівнюємо.
Борщ смачніший сьогодні,
чим вчорашній,
чи вчорашній, ніж сьогоднішній
[сміється].
І так само рослина краща,
вища чи нижча, за цією особливістю.
У цьому оціночному
розсаднику посіяли,
щоб створити ідеальні умови,
і спостерігаємо за ростом і розвитком.
Коли сорт створений,
спочатку він проходить
державне сортовипробування,
щоб зареєструвався,
а потім, якщо вже позитивні
показники його проявляються,
то він висівається на певні площі.
Ні-ні, це не мій.
А який ваш?
З червоною відміткою.
— Це я хотіла брати, вирізати.
— Забирай.
Багато ти хотіла.
[жартує]
Та отож.
Ми приїхали для того,
щоб зібрати цей розсадник.
Це один із пізньостиглих сортів —
Глухівський 85,
який на сьогодні уже
повністю достиг.
Що ми передбачаємо
цією роботою?
Ми з цього розсадника
відбираємо кращі рослини.
Елітна рослина — це краща рослина,
яка задовільняє потреби селекціонера,
який ставить загалом
вимоги до сорту.
Щоб він був (у цьому випадку)
високоволокнистий,
щоб він був безканабіноїдний,
щоб він був високоурожайним
по насінню.
Так, значить, я оголошую:
я приступаю до відбору елітних рослин
сорту Глухівський 85.
Пішли.
У конопель важливою
ознакою є висота.
Вважалось, що чим вище стебло,
тим вище вміст волокна,
але не завжди.
Була розгорнута селекційна робота,
яка дозволила значно
підвищити вміст волокна.
І 1972 року, одночасно з цією роботою,
виникла проблема створення
ненаркотичних конопель.
Це взагалі був нонсенс,
ми не знали,
з якого боку взагалі підійти.
Ми знали, що в коноплях,
а в якій частині знаходяться
канабіноїди, ми не знали.
Я вам скажу, що канабіноїди
знаходяться у всіх частинах рослини.
І, зрештою, 1980 року
ми вже мали перші сорти.
Я навіть можу назвати:
Юсо 14, Юсо 16, Дніпровська однодомна 6.
Три сорти.
У нас є науково-дослідне підприємство.
Ми наразі займаємося наукою.
Наша компанія має досвід
роботи з різними сортами.
І на цьому етапі у відкритому ґрунті
та у закритому в теплиці
ми намагаємось виводити нові сорти
та експериментувати з різними
технологіями вирощування.
Тому що якщо в теплиці — це просто
класичний метод вирощування,
на полі в нас вирощування
під крапельним зрошуванням.
Пішли.
Веди.
Три роки тому ми дізналися про те,
що в Україні є такий інститут,
який займається коноплями.
Ми працювали за кордоном
і, чесно кажучи, не знали,
що таке є в Україні.
Ми приїхали, побачили,
що так, дійсно є такий
науковий заклад,
який має дуже велику історію,
дуже великі об'єми, площі та багато людей,
вони мають дуже великий досвід.
І ми вирішили, [що] в нас є щось,
якісь знання, і в них.
Тобто ми почали працювати.
Наш науковий заклад
організовано 1931 року.
Інститут має у своєму розпорядженні
1000 гектарів землі.
Основними культурами у нас
є коноплі і льон.
Займаємося вирощуванням
високопродуктивних сортів,
які найбільше дають можливість
отримати насамперед насіння, волокна,
ну і, звичайно, канабіноїди
не сходять зі сцени.
Ну й одночасно медичний напрямок,
нам потрібно цьому вчитись.
[російською] Кожний зразок — цінний.
[російською] У нас є по волокнистості,
[російською] де високий вміст волокна.
[російською] Є по відсутності всіх канабіноїдів.
[російською] Є по якості волокна,
[російською] є по скоростиглості
та морфологічних ознаках.
[російською] Зараз навіть маємо зразок,
можна сказати, медичного напряму.
[російською] У нас є в колекції
Глухівський 58 (Вікторія).
[російською] Вікторія — сорт,
що не має жодних канабіноїдів.
Коли ми приїхали до Інституту луб'яних культур
та почали показувати ті технології,
за якими працювали за кордоном,
співробітники дуже скептично
були налаштовані,
тому що ми працювали з рослинами
в умовах закритого ґрунту.
Умови закритого ґрунту — це є
дуже добре для селекційної роботи,
тому що за рік можна збирати
три-чотири урожаї.
Проте люди, які все життя
вирощували рослинки на полі,
вони дуже-дуже скептично
були до цієї пори налаштовані.
Тому що вважалося,
що якщо в тебе лампа,
то ти — наркоман та вирощуєш
винятково наркотики.
Проте цього року ми довели,
що ми можемо вирощувати
дуже гарно без наркотиків.
Це рослини сорту,
який наразі знаходиться
на реєстрації.
Тут високий вміст канабігеролу
та тут немає ТГК [тетрагідроканабінолу],
тобто — це абсолютно медичний сорт,
медичного напрямку, без психотропів.
Зберемо насіння,
потім будемо пророщувати,
аналізувати кожну рослинку,
щоб ми мали повне розуміння,
що знаходиться, які канабіноїди,
та будемо вирощувати рік за роком,
покращувати показники,
які є наразі.
Дуже багато людей,
які шуткують,
що медичний канабіс — це жарти,
але насправді це не є так.
Ми хочемо робити науку.
Ми хочемо показати
нашій державі те,
що ненаркотичні коноплі
можуть лікувати наших людей.
[російською] Іване Андрійовичу,
добрий день, це Ганна.
[російською] Послухай, Іване Андрійовичу,
нам треба буде дуже трактор,
[російською] тому що ми навіть елітні рослини
не зможемо [покласти] в машину.
[російською] Вони дуже довгі, високі.
[російською] Десь години до другої
чи третьої, ми тоді зателефонуємо.
[російською] Іване Андрійовичу,
я вас дуже прошу.
У конопель вся продукція знаходить
своє використання, вся буквально.
І насіння, і стебла,
ну практично й костриця.
Із всієї довжини стебла
ми отримуємо довге волокно,
але в процесі переробки частина
із цього довгого волокна йде у відходи.
Довге волокно значно дорожче за коротке.
Використання довгого волокна,
загалом, — це канати, шпагати, брезенти.
Довжина цього волокна —
це волокно з цього волокна,
воно має довжину,
бачите яку?
Воно має десь 30-60 міліметрів,
і з цього волокна зробили нетканий
матеріал, без прошивки, без нічого.
Оцей нетканий матеріал
можна використовувати.
Можна як утеплювач на будинки,
можна використовувати
в ті ж самі ковдри,
можна використовувати в текстилі
для виготовлення нитки,
і з нитки тоді вже використовувати,
виготовляти одяг конопляний,
ті ж самі джинси, ті ж самі сорочки тощо.
Є така велика-велика мрія та кроки
лише в майбутнє, лише вперед.
Коли ми отримаємо
нарешті законодавство,
щоб ми займалися не тільки
виведенням якихось певних сортів,
а йшли далі і намагалися
працювати в наукових [cферах],
як в медичному напрямку,
як ті чи інші сполуки будуть лікувати людей.
Це майбутнє, можна сказати, на сьогодні.
Увесь світ не може помилятись.
Не може помилятись.
Без науки не може розвиватись
держава, не може.
Коноплі перспективною
культурою стали.
І думаю, що це буде безкінечно.
Це зміст мого життя.
Не більше, не менше.